when we were learning about responsive
design we saw that a common pattern was
to use the master detail flow which is
what we're going to use for sunshine
here the tablet mocks we have a list of
forecasts on the left and then for a
selected item we see the detail pane on
the right this applies for 7-inch and
10-inch tablets both portrait and
landscape orientations in portrait mode
the columns are just a little bit
narrower but it's still a two-pane UI in
terms of implementation all of this will
be under the mainactivity then on the
Left we have the forecast fragment and
then on the right we have the detail
fragment on the phone we would still
have the main activity with the list of
forecasts and then selecting an item
would still launch the detail activity
here's another way to visualize it on
the tablet we have two fragments side by
side under one activity and then on the
phone we have the first activity
containing the first fragment selecting
an item will launch the second activity
containing the second fragment we're
going to break this up into multiple
coding tasks until we build up the final
layout first we'll build up the two pane
UI for tablets then we'll hook up the
communication between the two fragments
so that selecting an item replaces the
detail pane on the right then we'll
learn how to show an activated state on
the currently selected item so we know
what the details pane corresponds to
we'll also need to make sure that the
scroll position is maintained across
orientation changes after that we'll
update the detail layout so it's
optimized for these wider screens and
then we'll modify the adapter so that
this today layout looks like the other
days there's no special today layout on
the tablet so hopefully it's clear how
we're going to approach implementing
this tablet behavior and we're going to
step through it slowly one by one